das bundesministerium für bildung
wissenschaft und forschung ist in
mehreren bereichen ein wichtiger
kooperationspartner des
bundesministeriums für
landesverteidigung und des
österreichischen bundesheeres so gibt es
enge kooperationen im bereich von
wissenschaft und forschung mit
universitäten in der berufs und
erwachsenenbildung insbesondere aber im
bereich der schulen hier eindruck seit
dem ersten grundsatz last zur
politischen bildung aus dem jahr 1978
und in aktueller fassung 2016 die
gemeinsame umsetzung der
verfassungsmäßig vor diesen umfassenden
landesverteidigung
dabei fällt im bildungsbereich der
aspekt der geistigen landesverteidigung
zu sie erfüllen durch ihre funktion und
tätigkeit als experten eine wichtige
rolle in der schule und öffentlichkeit
in einem gemeinsamen projekt des
verteidigungsministeriums mit dem
bildungsministerium haben wir in den
vergangenen drei jahren den status quo
der geistigen landesverteidigung im
schulwesen zum ausgangspunkt genommen um
die bedürfnisse von lehrkräften nach
materialien und unterrichtsmittel
aufzugreifen und in einer gemeinsamen
tagung neue perspektiven und
möglichkeiten der geistigen
landesverteidigung zu diskutieren daraus
bieten sich gemeinsame forschungs
seminare kooperationen mit dem
bildungsdirektionen und entsprechende
follow ups an dadurch kann das ziel
einer umfassenden
sicherheitsvorsorge im krisenfall egal
ob zivil oder militärisch
bestmöglich im unterricht aufgegriffen
werden und dem jungen schülerinnen und
schülern vermittelt werden was es an
staatlicher sicherheitsvorsorge benötigt
um in unserer demokratie in sicherheit
und freiheit leben zu können
ich möchte an dieser stelle meine
kollegin frau bundesministerin claudia
tanner und ihrem ressort danken dass der
einsatz von informations- offizieren in
diesem ausmaß ermöglicht wird ein ganz
besonderer dank gilt aber ihnen als
informations offizieren die mit viel
persönlichem engagement und interesse
ein wichtiges bindeglied zwischen
bundesheer militär einerseits und zivile
gesellschaft und insbesondere schule
andererseits darstellen dadurch leisten
sie einen enormen beitrag zur
weiterentwicklung von demokratie in
sicherheit und freiheit